New York was the place to be last night
starting with Chrissy Teigen emotional
tribute to her husband John Legend I
feel crazy for being here I mean
honestly it really is an honor I truly
have the most incredible husband on the
planet our our everything there are
families grown together our careers have
grown together this is so sappy I'm
sorry I didn't cry during our weddings I
hate you John on stage Chrissy was
unable to contain her raw emotion while
accepting Glamour's Woman of the Year
award I see John accept these things all
the time he has a whole shelf full of
them so now I have one too and I'm very
I'm very excited she's the kind of woman
you write songs about have you heard any
songs about Chrissy Teigen before inside
John presented the war to his queen with
a swoon worthy speech I have a career in
the music business but we all know who
the star of the family is no he's not
intimidated he's going to do a concert
tonight but about going back to work
after this
later that night Chrissy joined her man
on stage at the taping of his
iHeartRadio concert
I'm so happy you graced us with your
presence on stage
could use some spicing up there all of
me duet airs this Sunday
[Applause]
[Music]